[Music]
well I'm Justin this is my beautiful
wife Lauren and we live just outside
Chicago in Hoffman Estates Illinois my
parents are actually divorced so money
wasn't a big conversation with my family
internally I learned a little bit for my
friends parents but that's just kind of
ambient noise and I really didn't pay
much attention to it
I knew money was important and I knew I
needed to save and invest but really the
whole purpose of why I think was missing
and no fault to my parents I just think
there was a little bit of even a
disconnect in my brain as to why that
was so important and then we got married
and our financial struggles began I
guess you could say we thought we were
doing well and we borrowed for
everything yeah want a new couch go
finance it want a new TV go finance it
on a new car
go finance it you know I was the one
that was paying the bills and stuff and
it like I just kept looking at the
numbers and I'm like we are out of money
again and I knew what the problem was
but I had no solution and that was kind
of where you know I kept going to him
saying let's do something about this
ended up working all the time and trying
to sell as much as I could so I'd sell
more so that we could then buy more
right now we'd buy more and then now I
have to sell more okay well if you saw X
Y & Z then we can pay the bills you know
in the next two week and it was almost a
game but it really wasn't a fun game we
were doing okay in the sense of we could
cover everything and there's a little
bit left over and so I felt since I was
doing well in sales and my career's
trying to take off that I've earned the
right to buy a brand new truck
the way I justified it was I only need
to sell this much each month to be able
to pay the bill for for that a truck
well you also super jobs and then well
and that was that was what finally did
it was the fights with jobs because we
weren't budgeting because we didn't know
our financial situation we did a quick
math calculation to figure out how much
I needed for a salary so I could try
think
[ __ ] what would work I got what I
thought we needed and it's like a month
or two into me at the new job and I was
wrong on the math we were struggling we
had had our first son here before and we
had the birthday party I had gone to the
store to buy you know food to feed our
family and you know as I'm driving there
I'm thinking to myself okay so this card
is has like ten dollars left on it this
card has like $20 left on it I'm like
there's no way I'm gonna be able to pay
for all this food we had the birthday
party but I was I was just done I was so
tired of playing the game and shortly
after that I listened to Dave's book
because a friend had recommended it to
us and it was one of those we're like
sure why not let's try it you know kind
of thing because we had no other option
at that point and so I listened to it in
a day and I was like Justin you have to
listen to this if you do nothing else to
this week today whatever listen to this
book because that's we need to do this I
don't care what you think about it where
I was doing it she asked me to read the
book and I told her no for a few weeks
and then just one day I downloaded it
and put it on audio on my car finish the
book in a matter of just a few hours
came home and said alright honey let's
cut up the credit cards something
clicked it was like it was that turning
point that made me realize that we have
to do something different and it was
that information that helped just kind
of structure it in a way that made sense
that nobody else had laid it out like
that well we had a plan then once we had
like something to follow or some sort of
you know guidelines it made all the
difference in the world but you know it
was it was definitely a turning point in
not only our financial situation but our
relationship as well I'm not saying just
because we read the book it changed
everything but it gave us the path to
start changing
I'd say probably bout six weeks after we
read the book we
Financial Peace University age we were
already into the budget we already had
started paying some stuff off before we
did it you don't even really realize how
bad the situation is until you put it on
paper wait what the heck did we do here
and you kind of have a real aha moment
when you actually sit down and go
through it which i think was part of
where that was is you really add it up
it's like we really do need to do
something here or we're not putting our
kids through college we're not moving
forward in life and then it hit me
about a few months in that a huge chunk
of our budget was the car payment the
truck that I so rightfully deserved but
I realized that that car payment could
open up a huge door in our budget so I
came home and I said to where we need to
sell the truck and she couldn't believe
that I had even brought that it was one
of those like who are you and what have
you done with my husband
that truck was part of I deserved it but
it also gave me the opportunity to try
to show off to people and I realized
that that's not what life's about
and that's not why we do what we do on a
daily basis and just giving that up was
not only a huge benefit the budget but
it was it whole emotional change in our
relationship and allowed us to just kind
of look at things differently
the biggest I think driver of that whole
problem was that I was a very selfish
person I was okay it was all about me
and I love to entertain but I love to
entertain to show off not to entertain
to make other people happy as much as
that's not necessarily a financial thing
makes you realize what our role is in
the whole process in it I think that
opened up my eyes to where I looked at
life in general I think that was a big I
just changed yeah the book the Total
Money Makeover was a complete
perspective change I think for both of
us don't be normal like Dave says all
the time be weird it's it's awesome to
not have the burden of you know society
I guess you could say on you and you
know just living with a purpose and
having your money work for you instead
of you just working for your money and
knowing where your money's going it
definitely is a huge life changer
everybody that we knew thought we were
crazy and after we did that free scream
her co-workers all saw it my co-workers
saw it a lot of our friends had seen it
and many of them now are doing it but
here you genuinely do it for the right
reasons and you don't care what the
world around you things you're doing it
because this is what God wants you to do
that's just cool how what that ends up
spider webbing into that's what this
whole thing is is you just build
momentum and just allow that to continue
to progress in it it's amazing what
continues to happen in a positive
direction in life it's just it was a lot
to go through and to take 17 months and
pay off 85,000 it was a struggle but at
the end looking back it was worth every
bit of sacrifice
to it I would not change I would not
change it for the world
change a 3-2
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]